first let me start by saying congrats on
the movie
i that my only complaint is i couldn't
see this on an imac screen and the
biggest possible thing
um that's it that's what i got all i got
i'll see you later
i we feel for you yes
jumping in um uh one of the things i
think about animated movies is a lot of
people
don't know the behind the scenes what do
you think might surprise people to learn
about the making of luca at pixar
i feel like the thing that always
surprises people is the timeline
uh and you know the fact that it usually
takes about five years to make one of
our films
yeah the the painstaking yeah i mean i i
think we've heard like how
i i mean and this is still worth
mentioning because i think
it's a natural thing to think of that
that something comes uh pre-made when
you don't know how it was made or that
we
would plug a cable into our brain and
then the computer animates
the characters uh that it's painstaking
and that it
doesn't you really have to work with a
diamond and a lot of rough
for for for a couple of years and so
there's different ideas so it's really
this adventure
in making it so you set off and there's
a lot of moments of actual we felt very
meta because there were some moments
where you feel really
uh lost and then you get back up and you
you go
and and chase the story again and then
that
there's a huge amount of collaboration
in the way that we
find the moments in the way that we find
the the the
performances you know the animators with
the animators we're looking for
style at first you know what how can
they move a little differently let's get
inspired by some of the things that i
grew up with that i love how and now
what do they bring and
and every moment can get elevated in the
way they move
so i mean i i think there's so many
wonderful moments but they're all like
they're all involving a lot more work
than what i think we
think yeah i think that a lot of people
don't realize that like the
transformation
from them from the ocean to the land
every
part of that has to be thought about and
designed and i think
if you do it well people just think it's
real that it's just
natural yeah yeah you're right actually
seeking a sense of effortlessness
uh it's always kind of the goal right so
simplicity we talked a lot about lessons
more
less is more it doesn't mean it's any
easier uh
to do it and it'll take you it'll take
time right i think
uh steve job was was the the the guy who
really brought that to the front
of of simplicity being so difficult so
yeah i i think it takes us a long time
and uh but we pour our hearts in it we
put a lot of the layers in it so we're
really excited to show it to the world
and um yeah and i mean you know you talk
about
the the the the wouldn't it be nice to
see in dolby imax and yeah we
we we really do miss that i think the
the solas i take on disney places you
can re-watch it
and stop it and look at all these
wonderful little details we put in it
speaking exactly of that i'm always i
love pixar movies and i love that
there's always buried easter eggs that
sometimes don't come out for a while
um can you talk a little bit about maybe
certain sequences people should push
pause on yeah they're
a little bit there's a few different
types of
of uh of things here what i
uh really treasured is putting
love letters to the culture
of italy so there's some that are just
actually all in the signage
and what i we had a lot of fun designing
the signage of the beautiful town
and you will find a lot of those in
there and they are as different as a
writer that is amazing from italy or a
director
the the golden era of cinemas of the 50s
and 60s one of the big reason we put it
in this period
so there's a lot in the set in the
setting
that we love to to put in there so that
whenever you're in that square there's a
lot to have fun with i feel
and then there's the ones that are more
of the classical
pixar ones which are like what um
where is the luxo ball where is uh
the pizza planet and i i i'll give you a
little bit
they're in the in the third act i want i
want
i went on in on too many details but
yeah i think that
that that the pleasure of designing the
sets it's that and then with all these
fun homages you know there's an homage
to us
marcelo mastriani if you're an italian
um movie buff there's a lot there's a
lot to look for here as well uh
andre can you talk a little bit about
there's an after the credit scene
um at the very end can you sort of talk
about that
sequence and was it always going to be
that or was it going to be how did that
form was was it ever going to be
something else um yeah we do have a
little button at the end of the credits
and
you know that came out of when we worked
with sasha baron cohen
um as uncle lugo he's so talented
he's so fun you just you know show up in
the studio and he's like how do you want
this and he tries it all these different
ways and it's really playful
and honestly we have so much fun
material that we couldn't fit in the
film
that we kind of said well let's add one
more little bit at the end so it really
just came from an
incredible abundance of really fun
material he gave us so much fun
improvisation that we
we were dying to put more in it uh if i
can ask
what was the last thing that you guys
took out of the film before picture
locking
and why we were always snipping little
shots here and there just yeah
tighten up the moments that was
definitely kind of an ongoing process
in terms of like an actual story beat
yeah that's an interesting
question i don't know if we absolutely
cut something kind of toward the end
um i do know a couple of things came
into focus
a little bit later like for example i
think the threat of the parents with
something that we were
trying to figure out how much to have
them in the movies so the fun of them
being on the trail of luca
came a little bit later as we found also
the performances so that was an
interesting
thing where like together once we got
jim gaffigan and maya
in the mix we realized oh this is so
much fun let's
let's put them really behind them and
let's have them have their own
journey through this because they had
something to learn to get to the ending
so that was something that wasn't
right there um halfway through that we
it came into focus toward the end
and yeah i can't think of something we
cut down
radically toward the end i think we were
always looking for places where
you could get away without dialogue you
know one example was at the train
station
at the very end when luca we used to
have him say
alberto you know like what's going on or
something like that but instead we just
took it out and just had him look at
alberto like
and he'd have his face say that you know
so i think especially
in animation when you really want that
just that performance
to to sell as much of that as you
possibly can so we really always looked
for opportunities
um to take some dialogue out and let
acting
do the job my last question for you
often with animated movies they can go
through radical changes during the
production process
can you talk about how this film was
maybe
a lot different at the beginning or you
know like can you sort of talk about
that kind of
you know the way things evolve yeah yeah
it's quite easy to do because i just
gave some commentary to deleted scenes
uh so yeah it was more
it was a stand by me kids on an
adventure there were sea monsters but
there were there were three of them
so it just it it became pretty clear
that we had to
focus in the movie a little bit it was
uh they were on a quest
they were in the quests looking for
magical object that would completely
turn them human so
we had the setting we had the rough
ideas of the sea monster the friendship
and but we had to focus in on luke and
alberto more
so it was a sculptural kind of process
well let's take houses
this is really complicated do we need
all this
right and then we didn't immediately
have the ending so
i i think halfway through actually a
great conversation with my best friend
kind of
boned in on the fact that not only these
friendships are
are really important in the way they
challenge us when we meet
but they're really important and and we
are in how we carry them into the world
and how often we have to go our separate
ways so that became
an important important thing because
then you had this kind of
oh we haven't we have an ending here
that felt right and it felt very much
also something i've experienced having
to
leave my home and so those things came
into focus halfway through the process
congratulations on this movie uh you
guys did such a great job with it and
i'm looking forward to watching it again
without my name
plastered across the middle
sorry about those don't get in the way
that is how we see it for years too
because we offer especially on zoom
because they have to
print those things that they're
bothering okay well yeah
hopefully you'll enjoy it more i'm
100 sure uh and you know hopefully you
guys will be making another film again
uh very soon thank you so much thank you
so much for your time